[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming to modern crises ancient gods but
much of human history nature was our God
we worship the Sun the moon and later in
Northern Europe tree God's human God
should have followed them and then
science arrived and it seemed to sweep
all of our gods away yet now science and
technology have perceived that where
once they used we used to think they
tamed nature their increasingly seen as
plundering the planet wrecking the
climate and at least in some quarters
gods are back in fashion so were the
ancients right and his nature the source
of all things and that which we should
cherish most closely should we build a
whole way of life or even a theology of
nature without that it's hard to help us
discuss this we have David King
Sir David King was the former chief
scientific adviser for both Blair and
brown and foreign secretaries Special
Representative for climate change to my
left we have Natalie Bennett former
Green Party leader newly appointed
Baroness and Theresa's May Honours List
making her the second and on the extreme
left we have sister guarantee European
director of Brahma Kumaris
their representative of the United
Nations and a key presenter at the Kok
climate change conferences were the
ancients right his nature the source of
all things and should nature be what we
guard most closely David what do you
give us three minutes in the Greek world
the seas could suddenly storm up and
people would be drowned and it was
obvious that the gods were doing this
and what you had to do is make
sacrifices to the gods in order to try
and appease them before making a major
journey but we have been on a triumphant
march since that period through the
advancement of
science medicine sociology engineering
providing us with an unprecedented level
of human betterment and well-being one
of the measures of this is that children
lived to maturity here in Britain if a
woman had seven children which was an
average for hundreds of years
only two survived into maturity now
they're all surviving into maturity they
all have children and so the population
of the planet is approaching 8 million
and will be 10 billion and so we have
been providing the energy we need by
burning fossil fuels we've been
providing food we need by taking out
forests over all of this period of time
we have spread our mode of living across
the whole earth and that whole earth is
becoming scorched by this process we
have in other words not put a value on
the natural world it is only by
attempting to understand how we lost the
sense of the essence of the earth that
we can rebuild our mode of living to
protect the only means of sustaining
ourselves yes we have to do what we can
to deal with climate change but let's
bear in mind this critically important
message thank you
Nathalie where the agents right we have
understood so little we have science has
been this giant lion stalking around and
it's immensely powerful and immensely
strong but you know maybe it steps on a
thorn in the forest and maybe there's a
bacteria on that thorn and maybe you
know the lion has antibiotics but
because we've been spraying antibiotics
around like they're confetti that
bacteria has developed resistance to the
antibiotics and the bacteria feels lion
but if we're gonna have a new god or a
new way of thinking we have to learn
from the ancients the Italians in the
1920s had a Probab when artificial
fertilizers first came in fertilizer is
good for the for this father and bad for
the son they might not have understood
the microbial and fungicidal systems but
there was a traditional knowledge that
looked at what fertilizer was doing and
saying this is damaging the traditional
systems of fertilizing plants so we need
to look to lots of traditional knowledge
lots of traditional understandings we
need to think about sociology we need to
think about economics so I've got a
suggestion for a God if you like what we
need is systems thinking we need to
bring together knowledge from lots of
different fields not think a narrow
scientific approach has all the answers
think that the past has some of the
answers to and you know if you want to
say how do we bring in systems thinking
my answer is sustainable development
goals they're far from perfect but
they're a start so you know I don't
expect to see it anytime soon but what I
want to see at least metaphorically is a
giant march down Whitehall chanting what
do we want systems thinking when do we
want it now
this is auntie what do you think were
the ancients right should we value necks
above the wall thank you for this
opportunity I have to say that
spirituality only came into the
conscious realm of the environment
activists just a very short while ago
that's not to say that spirituality
didn't have thoughts about it earlier I
myself have been connected with the
earth charter which was being created in
the 80s at the UN in Geneva and so from
that time on there has been a spiritual
perspective and when we started talking
about consciousness and climate change
it was a shock to people what does that
have to do with anything but actually
it's our consciousness that determines
our vision our attitude and everything
we do in relationship with the world
around us and the people around us and
so nature is absolutely something that
we can deal with only when we understand
what's happening within our
consciousness and spirituality says
whatever is my awareness that's going to
be my attitude to the world around me
and so when I have the awareness of my
own inner being as a spiritual being not
just bones and flesh but when I know who
I am then I treat myself Razoo with
respect but I treat nature and it's
generosity and it's abundance with a
huge amount of love and respect and so
the perfect balance between self and
nature is one of respect and love nature
has given and I love nature and give
back to nature my respect thank you
I just want to pick up on that and women
we're all talking about nature what do
we mean by because you've you've each
sort of picked out something about
nature wonderful you talked about nature
not being inert so when we talk about
nature what should we think about is it
just something passive is it something
that's not inert and where how do we fit
into it because well I think you to
begin with we could have a whole debate
and I don't want to go down this route
because I think it's particularly
fruitful but of course we are all part
of nature the plastic chair you're
sitting on has been created by human
beings which are natural and the other
way of looking this round there is no
such thing as a natural place left in
the world the depths of the Mariana
Trench the deepest bit of the ocean the
pathway that would seem most immune to
human beings is actually full of PCBs
and other noxious chemicals it's full of
plastic humans have had an impact on
every single inch every single bit of
soil humans have had an impact on but of
course we are also part of nature
so you understanding that interaction
coming back to what I said about systems
yeah the whole thing is one system we
are part of that system and you know
there are some fairly negative but not
the way I'd go about this reports are
saying you know you can look at us as a
species that's just wildly overrun and
if you look you know there are plenty of
examples of that from biology and we
know where that goes to what is
different about us is we have the kind
of consciousness that Jayanthi was
tossed aside ranting was talking about
and we can think about the impact we're
having and that is something unique we
so far as we know no other species on
the planet has done that so we can think
about what we're doing and that gives us
a huge responsibility and a huge
opportunity and I think if we look at
nature and the impact of nature and
again this picks up something sister
giantess in one individual animal almost
never in nature has a massive impact
it's a species or a population that has
an impact and so you know we need to
think as human beings as our impact and
how we can work together to change the
way we interact with all the other parts
of nature but we are part of that nature
- hmm David I think I think I was put on
this panel as the scientist as opposed
to sister giant II I am very close to
what she said and if you like I'm
therefore quite spiritual I certainly
believe that some of the older religions
and I'm now moving away from
Christianity and Judaism to Buddhism to
the Taoism in in China which in my sense
of more philosophies than religions and
in those parts of the world you'll find
there is a continuing respect for the
fact that we are a part of nature
every Chinese student in school today is
taught that you've got to have respect
for every other living creature there's
a sense in which we are all part of the
same thing and what I was saying is we
have come to regard nature as apart from
ourselves not a part of ourselves and if
you just look up the oxford english
dictionary see what it says about nature
it's those parts of the world that have
not been impacted on by human beings you
know it's it's it's a crazy definition
so my feeling is that and if I may say I
disagree rather more with Natalie
because Natalie's sitting science up as
the bad guy science is simply knowledge
I go back to the ancient Greek meaning
of that word it's it's knowledge and
knowledge is a good thing we can't say
the President Trump is a good thing
right so the the knowledge and truth are
are critically important where is the
problem in my view I think it is that
our economic system which is a free
market system deregulated
that has no respect for the natural
world and that's where all the critical
problems are I don't believe that that
system which I have to admit has
delivered human well-being across the
world I don't believe that system is fit
for purpose in the 21st century so
here's a challenge we're up against the
capitalist system as the exists how do
we change that are you are you saying
that you are in some sense
anti-capitalist that you think that the
capitalist system has run its course and
is now toxic economists are telling me
no no the free market system is okay and
the biggest free market failure is
climate change
I said well hold on climate change is
about to create havoc to the entire
planet for us and for other living
creatures I believe we've got 10 years
to get this right no more than that and
this means a massive exercise globally
are we going to manage that
under the present capitalist system as
it is now no so do we have to change
that system I've got no doubt we do I
just wanted to come back to David in
terms of I entirely agree with your
economic approach but just to say the
sort of I'm in criticizing a particular
sort of science and arrogant science
that says ok we understand a bit of
chemistry therefore we understand the
soils and what a lot of science over the
past three or four decades I know they
have failed to do was really ask the
question what don't we know said hey we
know this so we've answered everything
and there has been a culture within
science that has failed to acknowledge
how much we don't know I don't recognize
that well if that's what's the science I
was taught in in the 1980s in Australia
this is it was indeed like a religion we
have the facts you learn the facts you
recite the facts in the exam you go out
and apply the facts and that was the way
science was taught to me and it has
awake sighs has existed in significant
parts the operation has never been like
that and if I'm a scientist and I'm
sitting at the cutting edge of my
science and I publish a paper somebody
else may well shoot me down and
they've done is observed the world
better than I had right so we've always
got the real world we're trying to
describe you cannot equate it to
religion where you're pulling truth from
somewhere else right it is the real
world scientists are describing I simply
don't recognize that well it sort of
moves us on to the second theme which is
this notion of you know can we should we
harness nature for our benefit or should
we revere it for itself and on the
Natalie didn't I don't think she got
this impression from nowhere and so is
it is there a difference between the
kind of idealists ideals
science you're talking about and the
kind of science where Monsanto says
glyphosate is great trust has spread
everywhere and then later we go maybe
not let me take as an example the case
of antibiotics there is something that
has given human well-being a tremendous
boost so massive scientific advance
measured in terms of human wellbeing in
the United States most beef is produced
in Colorado in beef factories 90% of the
beef the calves are fed with alfalfa but
also with antibiotics and growth
hormones in nine months they grow to
full size whereas the it would take nine
years and this is then fed to human
beings and you're wondering why
Americans are bigger than others the the
point I'm going to make now is it's that
behavior which is harnessing the
economic system in the United States is
that use of science that is destroying
the utility of science antibiotics as a
result of what the Americans are doing
will become non viable they will no
longer functional so I I think what I'm
saying is the science is there the
people who use the science other people
who have to be if you like managed so
that we manage respect towards the
natural world okay but I mean
it sounds as if you're saying look the
science are pure and wonderful creatures
who distant search of the truth and then
some some corporate person comes along
and perverts the whole thing but there
are a lot of scientists who work for
those corporations and so is there some
do the scientists have some
responsibility to say actually mr.
Monsanto I'm not going to do that work
for you and you're misrepresenting my
science the last thing I would ever say
is that there are no bad scientists
there is many bad scientists as there
are a bad human being and so you can yes
you can work for Monsanto and explain to
everyone that Monsanto is good for the
world
what will you're doing is selling
Monsanto products now we all know that
you know what I mean is there a sense in
which then that kind of I know I'm
picking them out what corporate science
he's somehow at least spiritually
failing if not morally failing in fact
it's not just one part of humanity
that's to blame in a sense we're picking
on the scientists now but in fact if you
look at what's going on it's the shift
of consciousness from the spiritual
identity in which I relate to myself as
that inner being and I see each and
every one of you as part of my family
seeing you as spiritual beings also
without getting distracted by gender or
color or race or age or any of those
things and what happens is when I
associate my identity with a physical
form this is matter in a certain sense
and so we get materialistic from matter
our consciousness comes to materialism
from materialism we become consumers and
where the problem lies --is the consumer
society India was much more in touch
with its soul in the sense and much more
in touch with nature 30 40 years ago and
today one would say India is developed
and I would challenge that very strongly
and what happens today is that today
every single small town in India has a
shopping mall that didn't exist for
fifty fifty or even thirty years ago it
does today so I don't think it's one
part of humanity that's the cause I
think it's consumerism materialism where
we've forgotten about our own inner
values when we connect with spirituality
we connect with our core values of peace
of love of truth of happiness today we
connect all of these things with finding
them outside trying to find happiness
out there trying to find joy and peace
out there and it's not true but this is
then the whole advertising syndrome by
this product and you'll be happy forever
it's a joke isn't it but of course it's
part of the whole system of consumerism
and materialism like I think it's
interesting that you'd use the word
system there because I do want to come
back to you the argument for systems
thinking here and I think it always
listening to David talking about oh yes
you know these bad scientists defending
Monsanto or whatever but of course you
have to be a really where you've had to
be a really extraordinarily brave
scientist to investigate and come out
and publish a report against glyphosate
you've had to the sociology of this the
economics of this the practicality of
this is you have this thought that maybe
there's this never be impact you do some
experiments but you have to be
extraordinarily brave to publish that
paper now that's the practical reality
of the sociology of science and we have
to understand the sociology of science
and you know this is partly economic
systems but it's not only economic
systems if we think of another case
study which is where this is 20 or so
years ago now people thought that ulcers
were caused by stress and anxiety and
bad diets and there were a couple of
scientists in Australia who thought
actually this might be a bacterial
infection and there wasn't there were
some economic interests here some
manufacturers of antacids and stuff but
they weren't certainly as dominant as
Monsanto is in terms of glyphosate but
they had to fight enormous ly hard
because there was a sign
cific belief we understand this we know
about this we understand all of these
systems and to challenge those systems
particularly if you our generation
generally are a junior scientists
challenging the senior professor
challenging a raft of senior professors
we need to understand the sociology the
challenge the difficulties of that and
the way that institutions and structures
as well as economics stand in the way of
really understanding what's happening in
the world I don't want to spend the
whole time disagreeing with Natalie but
her description of science I spent 45
years in research that is nothing to do
with the science that I experienced
around the world while I was doing my
research in other words if you were the
Maverick you stood out you published a
paper and it was different from
everybody else you stood out and people
might attack you but do not believe that
you would be prevented or ridiculed for
publishing you and this person has now
been recognized with a major prize so
the system will examine what you're
saying critically because it's very
different from what is believed but you
are expected to do that as a scientist
and if you want to rise as he did above
the rest we all know you have to do that
so it's not the world of science that I
know can I just add and sometimes I've
heard scientists say that in fact
science doesn't get into the whole
system of values and technology is
separate and that's then getting into
the system of consumerism etc but in
fact every human being has values and
whether I'm a scientist or not a
scientist there should be the situation
where it's my conscience connected with
my values that guides me in my life and
because we've forgotten about
spirituality and said well that's
nothing to do with life all of this so
then we've forgotten about values and so
we come to a state today but we don't
have that same level of respect or
compassion
or humility or love anymore and so I
think again the big cry that I have is
come back to knowing who you are and
then you find all those values within
yourself and then the label of that is
spirituality
thank you um which brings us suppose for
the the third theme which is we've
talked about what's wrong but if we're
looking at a way forward and as you said
you believe we have a decade to put
things right is the answer going to be
as relying on a spiritual transformation
that sweeps the globe or should we put
our faith in time gesturing towards you
because you other person we've nominated
to carry this time is it partly we have
a political solution that's not it's not
either/or we need all of the above okay
so I I'm setting up the Center for
climate repair in Cambridge social
scientists sociologists everyone is
involved it is engineers as well why is
it engineers we have to refreeze the
poles the pole the Arctic Ocean is now
exposed in the Arctic summer to sunlight
the Arctic region is now heating up at
two and a half times the rate of the
rest of the planet and Greenland sitting
there is losing its ice when it's all
gone sea levels will be seven meters
higher than they are today
that's what's already on the cards so we
have to refreeze the poles now how do we
do that we are I've got a group of 2030
people around the world we're discussing
how we might do this this is an
engineering challenge I believe we can
do it it's like landing a man on the
moon although I at the time thought that
was a useless exercise but nevertheless
Kennedy says to the Americans we get to
land a man on the moon in ten years time
in the 1960s that was one hell of a
challenge right that was a really big
challenge and they managed it and I
think we can manage these challenges as
well but we need all the science and
engineering that we have at our disposal
and then at the same time as we move
forward we have to learn to return to
our level of consciousness are aware
of each other and what we are that that
weightless thing that is consciousness
we have to return to examine that
because certainly in most of our
competitive lives we lose sight of it
and so I I think we need both connectors
at one thing I think I'm right in saying
when you say it's seven metres I think a
large proportion maybe even the bulk of
the world's nuclear power stations are
within seven meters of the presidency
level and since it takes about a decade
to even shut one down that would
certainly argue for what you're saying
that we really can't hang around it's a
very pointed argument yes I'm just my
job no I I am put forward as a nuclear
salesman because when I was in
government 18 years ago I said I
couldn't see how Britain could be Net
Zero missions without nuclear energy I
no longer believe that and I saw nuclear
energy as a last resort but time--it
change is such a big challenge
I thought we even needed that last
resort so I think seven meters sea-level
rise 80% of the world's cities will no
longer be livable that's the real
challenge right and what is the first
big city to go under and it's imminent
Calcutta and across the water from
Calcutta is Bangladesh also going under
water 160 million people looking for
somewhere else to live if that's not
going to destabilize the planet I don't
know I think it could be a bit of a
problem politician what are you gonna do
about this come on well I must admit I'm
feeling much more comfortable now
because I'm entirely agreeing with David
in terms of what he's presenting is
essentially what I call systems thinking
which is taking you know I don't wish to
down cry science I just think that
science has to be accepted critically
and it has to be critical of itself in a
way that it often hasn't seen but if you
understand that problems have a
sociological and economic all of these
dimensions and we essentially have to
change everything and I think you know
one of the things we have to recognize
and it kind of ties when my point
thinking about nature is that humans
have impacted on every square inch of
this whole planet and we've damaged
every square inch of this whole planet
and we have to think about assisted
giant he said trading much more likely
and so this is looks like it is an
enormous challenge but this is where
Pat's what you might call the spiritual
dimension what would come in I would
perhaps call the the well-being our
quality of life dimension comes in
because if we created a wonderful life
for human beings while trashing the
planet then it would be really hard to
say oh we've got to take away this
wonderful life because we've got to stop
we've got to protect nature but actually
we have created a dreadfully unequal
stressed insecure desperate Society
around the world and the fact that we've
got a change for the purposes of nature
is actually really good news for human
well-being and existence and that's
we're thinking about what is well-being
what is a good life
it's really important part of this whole
issue and this is we're thinking about
what kind of balance in life is I mean
one of the things that perhaps makes
this really concrete and practical is
there's a certain sort of politics it
seems to be associated with the theory
that well I'm a politician and I get by
on four hours sleep a night well I get
by on three hours sleep a night now I
have my first degrees biological science
and I know it to be a healthy
functioning organism you need seven to
eight hours sleep a night and any
politician who tells you that they're
getting by on three or four hour sleep
it's either a lying or B shouldn't be
allowed anywhere near the levers of the
country and that you know kind of ties
all together all of this thinking about
that we have to think about our own
biology our own existence as a natural
organism but we've also got to think
about the politics of this and why are
people saying this and how does this all
fit together are any of our it's our
political system up to this because if
we take a ten year timeline and most
political parties know the political
system takes 40 years just to agree that
there is a problem never mind doing
anything about if Roger Hallam was here
I think he might be saying look if we
put our faith in the gods of Technology
or old-fashioned gods or the gods and
politicians were all sunk we're gonna
have to look to ourselves and get out on
the street does that work for you very
much so because in that question the
word
Kisan does our political system work and
what do you mean by our if you mean UK
well I reckon I'd probably get about a
hundred percent agreement in this room
that we have a broken political system
that's utterly failed that's easy
if however we look at say some of the
Scandinavian countries which not
coincidentally at some of the countries
that are doing best in terms of climate
and treatment of nature and also better
societies for people less stress less
than equal they are the most democratic
ones so I would say I come back to
whatever question you ask me if you ask
me about seaweed somewhere I will let
you get back to saying the answer is
democracy and you know this perhaps
squares with what sister giant is saying
is you know people trusting in
themselves believing in themselves being
empowered in themselves and what you
have is you what I would say is the
other side of politics the far right
that looks for you know the great leader
riding up on the white horse leading the
people to the new promised land or
alternatively you have a society where
you says say everyone's important
everyone can make a difference everyone
can make decisions about their own lives
their communities their society so yes I
think the answer is a political system
and that political system is democracy
and it's about time we made Britain
welcome okay um that sounds great but
let's say they reelect Ron do we have
time should we just go out that was the
choice well that I did a debate with an
American philosopher whose suggesting we
gave up on democracy because of Trump
and I said well that assumes that Trump
has anything to do with democracy the
American political system is less of a
democracy than the British political
system is of course but its political
system isn't it so if we put our faith
in your God I'm making you other
political guard is your political God
does he do great but she do great
speeches but chief bugger-all
well if it's one person I would agree
with your second characterization if
it's all of the people collectively
together empowered and engaged with the
time and energy to act then yes the more
she can do it all of the people together
can do it my own sense is that what's
happening within nature and climate
change is a huge huge wake-up call for
all of us to be able to look inwards and
realize that whatever is going on inside
is what's happening outside in the sense
that if this moment we see that our
minds are not in a state of harmony and
order but in a state of chaos there's a
tension between my conscience and my
values and so the struggle is going on
within so all of these struggles within
are being reflected outside in our world
whether in politics or our relationship
with nature and so plus we see whatever
it is that's going on
it started from human consciousness my
thinking and so I don't think it takes a
long time to change the way we think I
just think that at this moment because
we're at such a crisis I don't see an
alternative we have to shift our
thinking to a spiritual consciousness so
that then we can take charge of what's
going on within ourselves and then
express that which we know to be the
highest so that our relationship with
each other changes instead of division
and chaos it comes back to a state of
harmony and then our relationship with
nature can also come back to harmony
we've heard a little bit about democracy
and I'm just going to say that I think
we are suffering from the failure of
democracy in this country and in the
United States and in several parts of
Europe and this is a dangerous time if
I'm not going to suggest it's going the
way that it went in 1932-33 in Europe
but for an older guy like me it's
looking horribly familiar I think we
need to be very very careful because if
you go back to 1932-33 in germany there
are no Germans who believed what
actually happened would transpire so
it's a slippery process and already
we're seeing the breakdown in the
democratic system I'm gonna say who
controls the media it's a very small
number of extraordinary wealthy people
once again it's big money controlling
the media and do people follow the media
well I've spoken to the editor of The
Daily Mail when he was running an anti
vaccination campaign and he said nobody
listens to what the Daily Mail says now
he knows that's nonsense he's not just
selling copy he's influencing people and
so I think the danger is that we have
allowed a very small percentage of our
population to acquire enormous wealth
and a very large proportion of our
population in the 6th wealthiest country
in the world still on the streets so I
think we have a broken democracy and we
need to think about that in a way that's
a sub issue but it is important because
everyone can see there's something wrong
and then 1930s in Europe everyone saw
something wrong and there was a
polarization and that polarization
doesn't always end in the right place
well ladies and gentlemen I'm afraid we
have run out of time all I would say
from all of that is choose your gods
very very care
[Applause]
you